on the surface Venezuela is a Catholic
country but when the Spanish arrived
here 400 years ago they forged a society
of many religions and races including
African slaves who practiced voodoo once
a year one offshoot of this mix of
beliefs draws thousands of Venezuelans
to a mountainside most are Catholics but
they also heed the call of the spirits
Walter Gomez has been coming to Mount
sorte since he was a teenager he belongs
to the cult of Maria leanza a group
influenced by African voodoo legend says
Maria leanza was the daughter of an
Indian princess and a conquistador
conflict between the Spanish and the
native peoples drove her off at Mount
sorte she and other Runaways took up a
new life - her cult Maria leanza has
magical powers once a year her spirit
and others return to mount sorte through
spirit mediums they heal illnesses and
solve problems and for a weekend
Catholics become voodoo worshippers
tonight Walter is offering his body as a
vessel he begin as a possession ritual I
prefer atomy to get ready to go in a
trance there comes a time in which I
feel like everything shuts down and
everything stays silent
just as in African voodoo the spirit
demands blood but here in Venezuela the
purpose is to purify Walters body
wellness I'm gonna get through the
traumas the blood that He shed cleans
your body the way Christ did when he was
crucified
the spirit possessing Walter gomez
demands more blood the instrument is a
bicycle spoke adorned with a Venezuelan
flag
I've seen things on law you don't feel
pain you don't feel anything absolutely
nothing
not PD or love or caring when you are in
a trans he'll end your body but you're
no longer there fully possessed
Walter can now help people by reaching
out to bad spirits in them and curing
maladies this man wants to atone for
pain he's caused his father in the
presence of the Spirit he can let loose
his grief my father is suffering for my
fault and you have to help my mother
they're suffering for these people why
do they do that never never look at me
my grandfather why waves of intense
emotion pass over it until suddenly he
springs up relief
finally after hours of being possessed
Walters spirit returns to his body
address the needs of many people tonight
and while he still feels no pain
he leaves with very real scars I
understand because it's a sacrifice to
heal someone and is worth it it was
worth it to be caught to be able to give
his spirits work done
Walter can relax and celebrate watching
as other spirits using other bodies
continue their efforts